hey grammarians hey paige hi david so
we're going to talk today about the
oxford comma
which is just another word for another
name for the serial comma which is
normally when you have a list of things
you punctuate them with a comma after
each item so for example in this in this
sentence i'd like to thank my parents
kama mahatma gandhi kama and my pet
hamster or in this example his favorite
artists are elvis kama a tiny norwegian
harpist comma and frida kahlo now this
is a pretty big
um
controversy in english is where to put
this comma uh
some style guides for example the ap
style guide recommends that you don't
include this last comma
the style guide that khan academy uses
the chicago manual of style does
recommend it
ultimately this is less about grammar
and more about style less about sense
and more about
taste because you could make i think a
pretty convincing argument against each
one like whether to use the oxford comma
or whether to not use the oxford comma
paige could you take me through the
possible
ambiguity in this first sentence sure so
this sentence without the oxford comma
can kind of look like you're saying that
your parents are mahatma gandhi and your
pet hamster which is pretty crazy right
and the second one uh is is a sort of
sentence that could be used to make the
argument
against the oxford comma so his favorite
artists are elvis a tiny norwegian
harpist and frida kahlo and it could be
argued that you're saying that elvis the
rock and roll progenitor
hip swivel guy
it was a tiny norwegian harpist which is
not true
um both of these things
are kind of examples of
assumed opposition that we're using
we're using mahatma gandhi and my pet
hamster to
explain or clarify parents or that we're
using a tiny norwegian harpist to
explain or clarify elvis and this is not
the
case
you know i think
you have to choose which kind of
confusion
is more important for you to avoid
frankly the way to fix these sentences
is to put the uncertain thing elsewhere
in the sentence so probably last like
i'd like to thank
mahatma gandhi my pet hamster and my
parents you know and there's no there's
no confusion no matter where you put the
comma there or his favorite artists are
elvis frida kahlo and a tidy norwegian
harpist yeah that does a good job of
avoiding that confusion
you know a good a good craftsman never
blames their tools
that's all i got to say about that so
paige and i are here to report we're not
here to make law you know we're we're
trying to tell you about the language as
it is and the way people use it and what
we do at khan academy is we do we use
the oxford comma so parents comma
mahatma gandhi kama and my pet hamster
or elvis comma italian norwegian harpist
comma and frida kahlo yeah you have to
find a style guide and stick with it and
sometimes you know that depends on
if you're writing for a newspaper that
uses a particular style guide or if your
english teacher has a particular style
guide that they want you to abide by
that's what you should follow
exactly different people will tell you
different things the key is to be
consistent
that's the oxford comma that's the the
debate over it and it's really all about
a false sense of these being a positives
so
keep a wary eye out
that's the oxford comma you can learn
anything david out page out